BACK TO "STATEE UNIO"
I'M NNA KEILAR.
BENTENTER IN THIRUMP IS GOING T
FAIONS. WEE SAW REPUBLICANS
CIRC TNDNTHA SINCE THET ON.
REPUBLICAN GOV
ASA HUTCHION.R, WSO MUCH FOR
WITH UT OF YOUR SUND
MAR-A-LAGO.OF TOP SRE
CLASSIFIED AT THE HIGHESSECURIT
ATTORNEY, A FORMER DHS OFFICIAL,
YO ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE WHEN YOUE IN CO
PRESIDENT POSSESSED THIS HY
AS
UNSECURED RESORT? S I'M CONCERND
AND DERSTAND THE NEED TO
RETRIEVEHOEN, ASSSMAN TURNEROI T
WHY?DO NOT HAVE D THE GGON
WHD THITE  THOSE DOCUMENTS THER?
THAT THEY WANTED THE
PRESUMABLY IF THAT WAS THE CASE?
ANSO THOSE FACTS HAV
DETERMIN
AND SO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
INTHINK WE ALLAKICIENT
DEEP BREATH AND SAY,E'NG
TO HAVE TOT ACTSAT COME
THERE IS SOME URY IN I
THE SEARCH OF A FORMER
THE AMERICAN PC WANT
UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND RIGHT NOW D THE
RCWAD
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S SIMPLY BEUSE THEY S THE
DONALD TRUMP AND THEY QUESTION
OV
AND WHETHER IT'S LESTRMEANS TO
PURPOSE.
WE'LL HAVE TO BE A LITTLENERAL
T  GETTING
INFORMATION OUT THIS WEEK.
SOME INFORMATION. ENCOUGED HIM
RELEASE THE AFFIDAVIT IN
PROVIDE AND SHED MORE
INFORMATION ON WHY THIS SEARCH
EXTHE GN
HEARD INVESTIGATION.
OVERREACH OF ITS AUTHORITY.
>> DO I KNOW THAT THOFMATERIALH
MAR-Y WON'T PUT
THINGS IN THOSE BOXES TO ENTRAP
HIM?
>> I WIL SUR
TYRANTS PAY
E,
WHAT WE THOUGHT ABOUT THAN
THEYPLE. MORE RE'S SOCIAL
MEN AT RISK?ELL, T GOP IGO BE EE
THE PARTY OF SUPPORTING LAW FOE
FBI.
AS UNID  ATTORNEY, I
WORK WITH THE  THEE
FEDERAL LAW FO
AGENCIES.
RO SE FOLKS ON THE GROUND DO
TO ENFORCEE OFH ISDAMENTO THE I
DEMOCRACY.
THE IST YES, W TO PULL BACK
CASTING JUDGMENT ON THEM.
NOOUBTE -- HIGHER
UPS ANDE
THEY DO I'CASES ASL.
ACTIONS. SEEN,OU WRONG
BUT WESAY THAT WHE
THEY WENT IN AND DIDSEARCHTHAT
TABLE, IT IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, I T
SAID HE THAT. SIMY CARRYING OU
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THT
A MASTD OFF ON.
ANEY IN THER
THEYRI TAIN THEIR
BE, T
WARRANT.S BE -- LET'S SUPPORT E.
LET'S STAND WITH DEAI OR YOU
O DOOBO  AWAY FROMY.PORTANT WE
>> I TALK TO ABOUT . H
ARKANSAS HAS AN
IF REPUBLICAN STESNGOR WO HAVE
THEY WOULDN'T RW
OSAN-LED
ST THE
?
CAART
>> ANSWER IS, YES.
ANI HOPEE ALL
THE NUMBER OS T BECAUSE INNSAS,C
DRAMATICAL.
LASTEAWE 3,000.
AT'S GOIS IN ROUND
NUS E UNWANTED
OR MIGHT BE UNDER DIFFICULT UMS.
SOE GOT TO PROVIDE THE
MATERNAL CARE,
TOE ABLE TO PROVIDE CREASED ADO.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE WE'VE N
E .IT WNTICIPATE
MORE LIVE BIRTHS, WHICIS
GO TETHING W
SO, HERE IN ARKANSAS, WE HAV
MADE PROGRES REDUCING TEEN
PREGNANCY, INFANT
MORTALITY RATE IS NOWHER
THOUE INFANTS THAT
DIE IN THE F YEAR AFTE
BIRTH.
CARE SERVICES ICAID
FOR THAT MOMAT YOUNG IN THE INCA
OUTCOMES,  FOR
THE MOM ANHE CHISOMETHING IN NE
FACING MULTIPLE CHALLEGEDLY CON
FACEBOOK MESSAGES WH
WILL USE PRITE INFORMATIONCOMPLN
AND DO YOU THINK THIS IS
>> FAMILIAR WITH THAT SPECIFIC A
PRO-LIFE LAWE HAVET HE
WE SAYHA TO
PERFORM AN ABORTION ANE
PENALTIES IS AFTER THE PROVIDER
WOMAN.T WEAV
DER IN THI WASMAGE
>> WELL, R.IT'S NOT --
DON'T GO AFTER THEM,
YOU'RE SAYING? YEAH, DON'TTEE
TARGET OF THAT.
SE PROVIDR SO
TE PROVIDER THAT SENT THMEDIT WA
VIOLATION OF
THERE' PENTY
R WO
SYATER.WE WANTO I THE HEALTH.
WE